okay for those who are joining our
livestream
we are talking about the complicated
topic of columns so this has to do with
how to do operations that apply to
columns of an array right correct we
have discussed these a few times and the
main point today perhaps is the
connection with another function we have
recently introduced subsets map and
symbolic position specs so if you go to
main this subsection of spam and so the
first point I wanted to make here is
that four part specs we have spam a
symbolic specification just right and
for position specs we have end and
something that I have realized recently
is that band has the same structure as
span so it has an initial point final
point and step so that's very powerful
because it allows us to specify lists of
positions of a very in a very flexible
way including columns and rows so
perhaps last time we discussed these we
were talking about slice you remember
the concept of of slice yes yes
positions like a symbolic precision spec
but they have an impression now that
band is enough and in fact probably more
powerful than what we were discussing
there because this is you this notation
is very well except as we pointed out
here there's the sort of a special case
here
[Music]
that would be I mean in other words well
ok go ahead over you yes so the idea is
that for example we wanted to have some
sort of precision spec for columns and
rows but with the head column and head
row are already taken so I was wondering
whether we can use this connections back
with band have something called a column
band or a robe and you know for example
and then we could use these
specifications of columns and bands in
all the functions taking taking position
specs which I list them and in
particular also know subsets that but so
are you saying that we would also use
band in those functions yes because band
is a very natural symbolic position spec
because it's a it represents a
collection a collection of positions
so you're saying replace part does it
already work to say replace part of it
doesn't unfortunately it doesn't right
now band is only supported in sparse
array I'm stupid okay bands could work
perfectly in any of those functions
there right so we could say band of blah
blah blah 1 1 comma 6 6 arrow X for
example and that would replace the
leading diagonal of that matrix but with
an X exactly at least instead of instead
of X we can specify the six elements of
the of the Taeyang
you know which is what spy summary does
okay so are you saying
um I mean you're proposing here that if
I want to replace column three that I
would say column band three arrow X yes
that would replace all elements by X or
if you're going to specify explicitly
the elements of the column to give it a
list of elements
I mean okay what are the alternatives to
this the alternatives you're saying that
it would be better to have a symbolic
specification of columns like column and
column band of three is equivalent to
band of let's see 1 comma 3 6 comma 3
correct yes and then we would have to
say 1 comma 0
this step is vertical because otherwise
this step the default is steps 1 1 okay
but how could it get from how I say I
say it we just miss I say well it's an
interesting idea this is an interesting
idea okay but but then so basically what
they wanted to have is a general
language and then we can think of
shortcuts to it here I'm just exploring
two generalizations how to insert or
extract a race because sparse array
allows that to insert a race or multiple
bands in the other section but this is a
bit more complicated
right okay
so the alternative that we had discussed
in the past was to have specific
functions so we would have a column math
column extract column delete exeter and
and my water was that this could
potentially be too many functions well
my point of view would be by the way I
mean do you expect that array of column
band three would work no I
so colon band is a position spec so part
only accepts pod specs fair enough but
so this right now is all comma three
right which I think it's simple enough
yeah it's not grotesque okay so let's
talk about column map so that's really
map at
[Music]
what was that - cyclist a nice array as
this version 12 I'm running here so this
is a little bit funky okay fine
we got some random array here
you
okay so now what are you saying if I
want to apply F just to a column of this
how do I do that right now friend know
we used annotation or comma three for
something that's not that bad
yeah I mean that's really not that bad
I'm not sure people know this as well as
they should but that's really not so bad
yeah there was I mean there was some I
mean is that really I'm trying to
remember right I don't think this is
quite finished which is part of the
issue
what do you mean finished as as an all
come a three works but I don't know that
like all three you know like if you have
it's nice or if you have a list of lists
that may or may not work seem to recall
there was some issue and I don't
remember if we patched it up so I think
I do remember so the the issue is the
relation between participates and
position specs and the proper way of
inserting participate in this argument
which is for position specs was to have
a double list but it has been
implemented with a single list which
tryna be misleading or a bit ambiguous
with some cases aren't we going to add a
message or something okay I mean look
this case no we don't want to have to
put an extra list packet that's really
good task it's not really grotesque
[Music]
right but right but then the right I
think there's an ambiguity there all
right let me look it up because they
don't have this off the top of my head
what did this mean here okay so that's
that's fine at position one three yes
okay what is the lead to just delete so
all those functions my part extract
delete insert and replace part of work
in the same way the position specs right
although necessarily with respect to all
that was one of the things we were
working on well I yes I think the point
is that one of them or two of them had
not implemented this yet but that they
could well I'm not yes I am describing
the current reality yeah and let's see
so the original discussion was to have
something which is even simpler and
that's why we started discussing the
column map column delete column insert
except what's wrong with us this didn't
work yes so this is one of these
functions that has not yet implemented
all comma three but it's good okay so
let's look at replace part so so here
and I'm talking about part and permeate
which have functions that do not use
position specs so but we discussed also
the possibility of having a column
version of part and permeate what
hitting it's yes so the what is
implemented there so a way of extracting
directly a column when you say column
part but I think this is simple enough
what we saw before that there was all
comma two or something exactly exactly
yeah so it's something very simple so I
don't think this need and just listing
what we discussed the previous time okay
replace part how does that now work with
them so replace part takes
a pattern of positions right so you
would say you know blink , you know want
3 to get is should we allow wool in that
case - I think so for persistency were
there the rest well yeah but the others
don't take pattern so I don't see LCD
the argument I think there's a weak
argument for allowing wall here but but
let's come back to that ok ok so what
other problems are we trying to solve
and these look pretty good actually I
think we're happy with with the notation
all comma something then we don't really
need the column notation I think the
column notation as you pointed out is
gonna be a big mess and there's a lot of
typing there so having support for band
which already exists that has a natural
notation I think would be good enough we
cool yeah but we don't need it as you've
said for the rectilinear stuff we just
say all comma 3 and things we only need
bamboo am i doing diagonal stuff right
exactly
it's quite general actually okay so
let's keep looking at this now yes so
then the next thing we were discussing
is that in what we have discussed we are
actually mapping on the elements on the
code of the column but what happens if
we want to map own the colon itself so I
think this is exactly the same thing we
have been discussing with respect to two
subsets map which is a way of now that
example is very clear I think right it's
really a you know that's a column apply
or a subset
so what did we imagine in the subset map
notation what the poem here is that
because the requesters that for example
if we have 1 comma 2 in the third
argument that means rows 1 & 2 so having
a notation 1 comma all or okema 1
I don't think place nicely here the
problem is that subset map is really
subset my bad right yes well the point
that you're making is that F of my let's
say Center a 6 6 or whatever now we're
gonna say what right that's that you are
trying to replace something which is
part of this thing so for example if I
said comma 3 I would be probably
referring to the Row Row 3 but in fact
what was I doing I was saying before I
was saying something like this wasn't I
yes we were discussing this sort of
possibility so the generation or the
basic notation will be a list of of
indices in the third argument saying for
example 2 3 4 and then it would extract
those elements manipulate them with F
and reinsert yes so what you're saying
is that to do it for a column we would
have to say it would end up being
something like that ultimately yes so
overrated
but and that would be right because we
can say 1 comma 3 comma 2 comma 3 comma
3 comma 3 sure that's not right because
the the subset map is mapping onto this
whole thing as a single gulp and then is
re putting it back in again
right umm ok let's look at some of your
other current linear combination of
columns yes I think this is a very
interesting case that has been discussed
in in some forms sometimes which is
given our matrix how do you construct
another matrix in which the first column
has been replaced by the sum of the
first and third column for example a
very typical thing so the suggestions
they they give Gaussian elimination or
something is that right exactly
exactly God how do we survive without
subset map for 30 years
yeah so amazing how many of these
factorings of functionality one realizes
are more general than one expected okay
yes so I wanted to raise this issue to
discuss what could be a good notation
for this I don't have a good suggestion
actually further down there's a
comparison with dataset just to see
whether we can learn something
this query approach so if I had to do
that myself I could use query with
either with function which is quite easy
to read or something more functional but
more difficult to read
okay so why is subset map I see this
husband you know is reminiscent of
Korean and constructing and so on right
because it's basically taking it's
taking a multi-argument functions what
sometimes it's taking you know one case
it's saying F of the elements in a
column another case it's saying F of the
elements in one column and the elements
of another column right in fact a user
has pointed out to very recently that
query does not support covering which it
suit certainly does not support curry
yeah
before that yeah we forgot it it should
because curry really plays very nicely
with with operator forms yes yes yes yes
yes yes okay okay
so all right so okay the main point here
is in this case you are imagining why is
subset map F 1 of 2 does that mean yes
so what I wanted to do there is to have
a linear combination so I thought well
this is based on two operations one is
multiplying each column by a factor and
then adding them so so subset map is
only taking the whole collection of
things in this case the collection of
columns and doing something with them
which is the total
well right what you're saying is the
usual case of subset map just like these
are case of map map is a unary operator
is that what is the analog of map when
it isn't unary right so I mean we could
imagine a function in which we're taking
okay so let's take the example okay so
there is a unary map okay so the the
mechanisms we have four binary maps are
things like fold we also could say block
map F range of 10 to right
Sandara a livestream suggests the idea
that you've got subset map F comma
datacom opposition but the
generalization of that would be the
input position and the output position
right I was using that above with an
arrow both in our report yes so let's
look again at subset mattress I can just
to remind me how that's supposed to work
so subset map do we have an
implementation by the way in the in the
prototype of kernel it's still called
mutate at and we have a reference page
for our future ice reference page okay
so I can get I'm running some kind of
weird prototype building I'm not sure
the documentation is gonna work I'll try
it
okay okay so this is a multi nary
operator on that top-level list but so
the question is how let's see so that's
saying in subset map of that it's saying
take those positions apply F to the list
of positions ijk okay so that generates
F of e IJ whatever and then by default
it puts those back into the same
positions right yes because we expect F
to return a list of the same length
right so the generalization is that if
for some reason if returns a list of
shorter or longer lengths you can still
specify the positions that it will feel
yeah I understand but how does this
relate your column wise things item we
hadn't thought about that subset map we
only thought about it for the one level
list right because this notation with
integer indices is only looking at the
first level so the idea is that if
instead of having a list of integers we
have a list of pairs you can specify the
positions of a column
and then we can play the same game okay
so you're saying all comma three is a
column that's a single column it's a
single thing
so this by default would fill that
single column back is that right that
would just take I don't understand this
I don't understand there's two different
things going on one is you've got this
list of ijk and those are being come
together in a list yes but remember that
the basic notation here would be having
least one least two but you wanted to
have as some sort of exception so that
one two three was accepted meaning list
of list one list two history which would
be the standard position spec okay yes
so so then all comma 3 which again
perhaps we could accept with a single
list could mean all elements of that's
equivalent to map at of this is comma
all three isn't it no because that will
be mapping as to each element while
subset map will extract all elements of
the column apply or yes F of the whole
list and returns returning another list
there wasn't the right thing here apply
at because apply means something
different to us right we want to
construct yeah okay okay okay so this is
I see you don't want to map you want
more to do as you saying construct at
oh boy
so what that's doing is it's taking this
function f it's applying it to its
constructing F of the column three it's
feeding that back in again to cause
three but you also want the possibility
of having column you know having two
columns that just like so I don't know
sound there's two ways that the function
could be applied so in this case here
the function is picking up different
elements from different quotes columns
except them electric columns and it's
doing something to all of them whereas
here I understand there's a list packet
wrong because if there's multiple
columns here do you want you see what
I'm saying yes I do and this is going
back to the discussion we were having
with it died before the difference
between one list and two lists you know
and that's why the notation of column
band two or three is kind of clearer
because it's explicitly saying I want
the column two I mean I'm trying to
understand the subset map thing so
you're saying
I'm kind of wondering will the name is
Rotem ever it should be map within or
map across
so let's imagine that we said map
lacrosse in which and so the statement
there in which the list of parts so this
would say map across F e 1 e 2 IJ which
is the list P I J are replaced actually
which that's basically what it is it's
this thing here are replaced by so
interestingly this is the analogue are
replaced by F of e IJ that list is
replaced by that which is very analogous
to saying to the notation you know a B
equals or we can do can't we F of 1 well
it's like the a B equals blah blah blah
blah F of a F of B right or whatever
whatever you want to use that so it's
it's kind of the functional version of
that of some kind of in-place thing
right we have not discussed the in
placed version of subset map but this is
the I mean the implies version something
like a equals matrix and then we we
change the value of a change some
columns or some rows of a
I see that perhaps we are using in place
in different ways now what about L value
X what about L values versions of map
across well I mean I would imagine it
will be some kind of set across type
thing the heck would it look like
it would be set across of a comma parts
Peck
well that makes the argument for why
isn't there a thing that represents so
it's it's the same argument right so
it's just a different order
so the second argument they at least a
182 corresponds to a the IJ corresponds
to a parts back and FB third angry but
it's wrong as though it's it's the
virtual value it's not a function in
this case in the case of set it's just
the actual explicit values but but let's
come let's go back to a I think you're
typing
let's let's go back here okay we've got
several different things going on we've
got a function this is like replaced
part this is like no it's not even like
replaced but it's like it really is like
a multiple map across matter hat and now
you're saying let's imagine that was a
column you know we can imagine a map
across where this is an array and then
what we want to say is my fundamental
view is that that third element
specifies a list of positions you know
and then F is going to be fed with that
list of positions no it's not it's the
elements to array at that list okay so
then F is given a list of the elements
of array at the specified positions
right but you know the question is how
structured is that array does the array
does it preserve the structure that
which from which it was extracted or
does it not right because I mean what we
expect us to return at least of the same
length no I understand I understand but
I mean so in other words let's say there
were two columns specified in the
positions thing let's imagine that we
had this case okay so let's say map
across array and then this was list list
all cover three comma
walk over five okay that's two columns
they're great that's that's again abuse
yeah okay so the question is what is f
given is f given is f given a a a
structured thing see for example let's
take that case and let's take the rather
nasty case where it was also specified
as six commerce at eight right that
would stow it
give me the elements for a column
together with I mean look the obvious
thing to give it is to take the array
and to use this as an extract spec if
I'm not mistaken yes but that spec is
not supported by struct even was brought
about by by part no I never takes two
lists well shouldn't extract shouldn't
extract support that what would it
return right would it keep the structure
of the array and return to fragments
there I think it could right I mean what
does extract do when you give it a list
of different parts right it gives you a
flat list of the union of those parts
okay so if I sit here two three four
five right that's a list of drugs okay
so now let's say I say 2 comma 4 5 what
went wrong though you need the two it's
not a uniform list right so the 2 needs
to be in a list I don't know why it
doesn't support that because it would be
even more ambiguous than enough already
is okay got that now I could also say
all common to here you should be able to
but I expect this will not work okay why
why am I getting these messages and
that's stupid other window do you know
how to reset that yes I think all right
now look up the option they Steve simple
I think that we've removed that from the
Preferences over this so so this could
work in extract so when we say all
coming to what would that actually
return for the old comma to would that
return just a single list of that column
or what it would turn a one one element
per row yes I think that's a list of
elements so that's there the second
column that's written a list containing
the second column and then one element
okay so so hold on so you're saying that
this case here that fails as well yes
the case that died and I want to support
because that's it properly and I'm the
use case okay all right so fine so then
this would be the same thing here
as this okay so if we use the extract
spec and whatever extract extracts is
what is fed to the F function right
right okay so and there's yet an outer
well we could imagine yet an outer thing
here I don't even know what that means
because there could be overlapping cases
of that but it's it's we don't want to
have to auto fold it will be better to
not have to auto fold I think the idea
would be we need to specify our row
specification of positions that
corresponds to the result of F and then
we reinsert and those positions okay so
look the default would be F array
positions right and that's equivalent to
positions or opposition's yes but so the
thing has to conform okay so let's say
you wanted to take two columns and and
squash them into one column like how
would you do that well following your
idea the first one would be a list of
little columns because I should not do
that let's do that okay so that would be
all comma 2 comma all comma 3 okay now
what and there we could say I am it's
always a single list or double list but
alkmaar for sure but I want to get rid
of column 3 and I just want to take
column 2 and add it to column 3
it'll be Altima three okay like this
right okay so that then relies on the
fact that M ICF takes two lists so in
that case F will be given two lists a
matrix the okay matrix of column 1
column 1 1 column 1 2 etc etc column 2 1
column actually I could have written
dealt with threes and twos but if I get
my idea um and then F has to return in
this case a single something whose
extraction this is going to insert just
like insert inserts back at a specified
position so that would be like r1 r2
button yeah okay
um okay sander on a live stream is
asking weather map across of sort data
all comma three would mean sort column
three would it I think so I don't
actually I don't think so because of
that the IJ business here we'd have to
have another level of that yes I'm
mister nothing this one level versus two
levels because I mean it's possible that
we should the question is how commonly
will this be used as a single list
operation versus a double list operation
okay but in any case so this would be
yeah that means sort column three now
how and put it back in
what do you think of the name map
lacrosse let us join across to it is
something much much much more obscure
that's a horrifyingly complicated thing
and so join as in well so I'm not
certain but but between
sorts across those values basically
somebody's sending something here what's
this I sent you the thing to fix your
messages Thanks that is incredibly
obscure actually it makes perfect sense
okay all right so the unary case okay so
in this in this interpretation this is
saying do that now if I wanted to let's
say I want to sort
umm I wanted to take elements 5 & 7 6 &
7 and sort those and reinsert them back
I will be typing this is that correct
yes but it's important to note that this
is an exception so they from the
position spec point of view it should be
least 5 least 6 lit 7 yeah which is kind
of grotesque it falls extract so it's in
extract least 5 6 7 is a position at a
depth at level 3 and not 3 positions
yeah I understand
so we can have an exception because in a
I'm going to be very useful but it's an
exception I think the more useful case
is going to be the column 1 well for
example the cases we were exploring in
the past where permutations and yeah I
know but this particular thing I mean
you know arguably this is such a common
operation you know that accumulate those
are such common operations that they
should be given to a function that just
does that
now I wonder what the analogous thing in
dataset is because um you get what I'm
saying I mean yes it there were these
examples I gave before with grey which
is basically dataset okay well if I have
a dataset who the old comma the function
that we apply it's just this does that
just work nice and some yeah I think
that just works
I mean let let's try it actually I would
see what should be do it's just have a
random integer ten but we have to
specify that the column we're going to
apply so that the b2 slash okay so
dataset of
so it's all rose but that's not right
that's not what I want to do is it now
say - so that would extract a second
column no yes no I don't think that's
right because I think sort is now going
to be applied to each element there
that's not right that's not right it's
more going to be this is more likely to
work okay that extracts what does that
do now
that's gonna chew
okay so that's extracting I see so this
is saying sort and extract column too
but how do we do the thing where we're
putting where we're only applying this
to column two but we're returning
everything I'm confused
I mean this diet this okay
[Music]
that's not right either that's not right
either oh boy
we've got more figuring out to do here
mm-hmm
we've got to understand the relationship
to data set maybe there's a kind of an
adverb for data set that needs to be I
[Music]
don't understand how data set is going
to apply to one column but return the
whole data set so to speak maybe it has
to be a map at yeah maybe this is data
set map at sort common - right this is
crazy
I don't know how to do this I don't know
how to do it that's not right all right
I think we need more work on this run
well anyway but a very important
conclusion of this meeting is that
subset map and the column operations are
closely related that's an important
insight it's also totally ridiculous
that we managed to exist without subset
map for 30 years and it seems now hard
to understand and makes me wonder what
other you know functional operations
there are that we should really be
trying to you know see all right well I
think that's probably everything that we
can achieve right here
[Music]
to be continued okay what do you are you
back in the u.s. sometime soon are you
yes this weekend inflamed back ok um all
right well good stuff everybody
hopefully it'll take you less than 50
hours to get there what happened was
that how many hours do you were getting
back from Brazil yes and my outgoing
flight was delayed a total of 29 hours
so it was a very very long trip back
recovering just out of pure curiosity
which airline was that American I see ok
fair enough
and what and how many did I don't even
ask what was the what was the story
behind it there were some minor repairs
and because people started getting
nervous
yes ensued and eventually the the crew
timed out we had to wait 12 hours and
then there was a second delay it was it
was just absolutely okay terrific
well sorry that happened
ok alright see you all soon